- How did your life story though,
end up becoming a part of a movie.
'Cause this wasn't your idea, right?
- No.
So many years ago Barry Diller,
at the time who owned HSN
home shopping network.
And you know, he bought my company.
He just went from one QVC to HSN and said,
Joy, you're coming with me.
That's it!
I'm buying your company.
You can't say no.
So that was one time I didn't say no.
So nonetheless, he asked me to go out
and film a show for him in Hollywood.
And we went out to dinner
with the producers,
prominent producer and I
dunno what got me started.
He started asking me a lot
of questions about my life.
This is many years ago.
And I stood up and said
goodnight and he said,
Joy, one day I'm gonna write your movie.
It is an amazing story.
And I laughed.
I said, oh.
That's great.
A few years later I'm
sitting in my office,
the phone rings and Ken says,
Hey Joy, I'm in my office with
this producer and this guy
and we're gonna make a
movie out of your life.
And I'm like,
okay!
Great Ken.
I'll talk to you next week.
(Joy laughs)
And P.S. you know David O. Russell,
I mean a family in Hollywood
to meet Jennifer and
Bradley Cooper and Robert de Niro and
David O. Russell and Diane Ladd.
That's just great.
- [Kelly] Didn't you kinda
start to be terrified,
Cause you're like, my life
is gonna be in a film.
It would terrify me.
- I know.
Really, I have faith in people in general.
I had such faith in David.
He called me at dinner time sometimes.
And it would be like 2
o'clock in the morning.
And he'd still be,
you know talking to me and
asking about parts of my life.
- It's cause he lives here
and no one shuts off here.
- There you go.
- Go ahead.
- Right, exactly.
So, when they went away to film it,
you know, he came back
with a five-hour movie.
So it really didn't even get into
all the obstacles in my life.
It was really amazing.
It was amazing.
- So, what we're seeing
is like a synopsis.
- [Joy] I know right,
it really was extended.
- [Kelly] Wow.
I know, I want the extended release.
- Yeah there you go.
So tell us about the new
show, America's Big Deal.
- Oh my goodness.
Well, we are so excited.
Thursday nights on USA network.
And this really is a game changer.
It's the first time ever,
shoppable TV competition.
- Yeah.
So entrepreneurs and small businesses,
you know over 90% of them
makeup the firms across America.
I think they're the
engine in this country.
And you know through this
last year and a half,
I said I really have to do something.
So the mission of this show is to
bring back small businesses
and entrepreneurs.
So they get this amazing
stage to pitch their products.
They're ready to sell products
and they get to pitch them.
We see the backstory and
how they've been impacted.
So the audience, the viewer
becomes the consumer becomes the buyer.
So you literally can sit there and
buy the product when you see it.
And let me tell you,
you're gonna be like,
how did this not exist
before or I have to have it.
Get your holiday list out.
- Or you're gonna be mad and you're like,
why didn't I think of it?
- And it's gonna be at a big deal price.
It's gonna be amazing and it's live.
So it's right there in the moment, right?
We're gonna have a million surprises.
And then, if that's not
enough that they get this
stage in front of America,
the person who sells the most
dollars of their product,
turns around and gets
to face retail titans,
national retail titans.
So Lowe's, Macy's and
I will be on the panel
for QVC and HSN.
And they will be offered a six figure deal
to put their product nationwide.
(audience claps)
So it's amazing.
It's amazing.